how reasonable or or how easy is it for
a guy to optimize his health in his 40s
and 50s because you're about 40 right
yeah I just turned 39 so 40 this year
yeah yeah okay so
yeah I've been investing since 15 years
old I've been doing the diet and the
trading and and then I was drug free for
10 years and then 26 I started getting
my hands dirty with Peds
um so I'm not I'm not really the you
know the most accurate 40 year olds
because when I look back on my
classmates that are now 40 oh
oh man those guys are those guys look 55
yeah yeah most most most of the guys
that I can go back and look at on you
know from High School on Facebook you
know because that's that's what happened
with Facebook all all classmates from
high school you kind of friend each
other and you're like oh and you kind of
like yeah like you're like you're on
YouTube happen to you dude like you know
or what happened to her oh my God look
at the scene to her like she was hot and
now like so how so how easy or or how
difficult is it for you to manage
Optimal Health in a masculine strong
frame while making sure you're not
damaging your body prematurely
again it's it's a full-time job but if
you've been doing for a long time then
it's just your standards of living so
I've always cooked my own food and I've
always gone to the gym and I've always
done my blood work and and well for the
last what is it 15 years I've taken some
Peds right to manage my my physique and
my health at the same time so for me
it's just easy because I I don't know
any different but if you're just getting
started man it's just a shift if you
come from general population you've been
eating McDonald's since high school
right like we talked about you continue
that lifestyle now you're a fat mess
yeah that switch is going to be rough
right and you don't even deserve trt
because you're so unhealthy that you
need to fix your health first because
otherwise your blood pressure is just
going to go up and you get all these
side effects so I think it's just a slow
transition to wherever you start from
now you know you start to learn how to
love training and then you learn how to
love nutrition and then you learn how to
love all the health screening and stuff
and then once you've got that in order
okay take a little bit of PDs if your
blood work shows that your testosterone
is low and your blood pressure needs
more management and and then maybe later
on you like a little bit of a master on
a Primo round of RGH and IV treatment on
top
um I think you should set two hours per
day aside for that which is a lot but
that includes the training and that
maybe three hours the training and the
and the diet and you know doing a couple
injections if you do so desire and
taking some supplements I don't think if
you if you invest into your physique you
can make it last such a long time
but not a lot of people don't do that
yeah I was gonna ask so what's your
go-to foundationals for supplements and
uh prescriptions and drugs that you
pretty much always use because I know
that you kind of like move in and out of
certain things you talk about on your
Channel I want to fix my fatty liver
disease or I want to fix you know this
sort of thing or I'm going to take this
out of my diet for a little while or
take these out of my regime what's your
like go-to sort of mandatory Baseline
you know foundationals right now for
supplementation drugs and prescriptions
yeah so that that changed so much as I
get older because if you ask the 25 or
30 year old me I would you know lay out
a hefty cycle said this is my base this
is what I'm going to do because I want
to be jacked and now that I'm 40 I mean
we're going to aim for kids this year
um so my cycle is going to be very
simple it's just going to be fertility
medications
ACG and HMG and if if that doesn't work
then I'll go with recombinant follicle
stimulating hormone and luteinizing
hormone it's a little bit more expensive
um so my my protocol kind of changes all
the time I think the foundation should
be diet and exercise as boring and
annoying as it sounds and it's a
obviously there is
the trading and nutrition you have to
you know but it is true that's the
foundation of it then as you look at
your training you can see if you need
some supplements for that whether that's
creatine or citrulline you know
no not anymore but my my being huge
aspirations are over over yeah I think
that creatine is damaging to your organs
like your kidneys or is it safe no no
you just need to stay hydrated
because the the old school mentality is
just that your creatinine levels are a
good indication of Kidney Health which
is a very poor indication of Kidney
Health gratinine is just a metabolic
byproduct of protein metabolism in the
muscle so if you have more muscle you're
more physically active you'll have more
creatinine and if you take creatine
monohydrates or another creatine on top
your serum creatinine levels are going
to be higher and if you're worried about
your creatinine do a 24-hour urine
collection test get an actual glomerular
filtration rate tested not the E not
estimated to GFR a true GFR with a
24-hour urine collection test and then
you'll see that your GFR is like 170
percent even though your serum
creatinine levels is very high and the
egfr is 70 but you're a real GFR based
on your urine is way higher than 100.
Celsius look yeah I'm sorry go ahead
finish yeah finish yeah yeah so so if
you want an indication of Kidney Health
look into cystat and C that's kind of
the goal that's what I use yeah yeah so
that's now finally people are that's
finally catching on because I've been
using that one for years you'll be
surprised there's very few Labs that do
it here Steve like like I know for me to
get mice mine done they'll they'll pull
the blood here
none of the technicians know about it
like I brought it up and they're like
What's it called how do you spell it and
then you know a supervisor comes in
what's it called how do you spell it and
they find it somewhere in some sub
manual and then they send the sample
down to California which is where they
measure it and they send the numbers
back from there right yeah yeah no it's
it's very frustrating when you realize
that you know way more than the medical
professionals that you have to deal with
to keep you healthy preventatively
because preventative health doesn't
exist they only have a reactionary
Health yeah and you get yourself sick
okay now you go do chemo you get
yourself sick okay now we cut out your
prostate you really have to take
ownership for this yourself like you
can't rely on the medical community
because it's more sick here it's more
just just just keep you healthy enough
that you're not dead and not sick enough
that you're in the hospital and by the
way take all of these you know 72 pills
that you need every day
you start reaching the medication you're
like
man it's just some serious stuff and
they did they forego all the drug
interaction so let's not even go there
so I think if you're 40 years old and
you're you know regardless of age if
you're really invest into your health
and you get educated on the subject of
Health
man you can you can improve the quality
of your life so much but just like a
regular job or a relationship or owning
a car owning a car takes time
right you need to drive it maintenance
and and you know the car and the human
body analogy is always valid treat your
body better than your car
you know people understand no
unfortunately not you need to clean your
car you need to wax it you need to make
sure you have the proper tires you know
the engine needs to be sustained and
then people know all about this but then
you ask them about their organ health
and they're like
I I don't know you know
they have these uh tests for cars it's
called Blackstone labs and I've used
them before great company and what you
do is you send them in a sample of your
oil
and then they measure the oil for things
like copper which might come off the
piston rings or seals you know various
other metals parts per million and then
they send you a lab back and they say
you know oh wow yeah from all of the
cars that we've measured the oil on
that's something like like the last car
I did on it was a BMW M5 and they're
like you know this is the average and
then this is where you are so you kind
of have an idea based on the mileage how
much wear and tear has happened on the
engine and a lot of guys in the car
Community will get geeky and really you
know do stuff like that to see you know
how much longer their engine is going to
last you know stuff like that but guys
won't pull blood laps because it costs
money like this is your body this is
your own blood like your blood's like
oil in a car right but they won't spend
the money or time on themselves
unbelievable right and it's the same
people that really love their pets they
they give their pets like raw food they
cook food for their pets they really
treat them like kings and then they eat
ads for nmn for your pets like like pet
chewables yeah showing up in my feed in
social media oh that's crazy so so I
hope that like in the end this is all
you have right this body is all you have
yeah and if you treat it really well it
lasts and it gives you such insane
return of investment like the ROI that
you get out of spending all the time in
the gym and cooking and Ivy bags Etc the
aura why did you get out of that is
insane because I don't have any of the
issues that most 40 year olds
face I don't know if the libido issues I
don't know if the acne issues no no hair
loss it's self-induced right I mean it's
just more convenient and so all these
all these gen pop 40 year old or 50 year
olds that I that I hear talk about their
issues I have none of it because I
invested such a long time and I I would
recommend everybody to do the same you
know and if you're not financially
secure instead of spending money on
Cheap Thrills you know going drinking
and you know that kind of stuff
um spend it on yourself man on your body
level that up first and then you'll see
that everything in life will be 10 times
easier I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out